expresiones internacionales que
apuntaban a que china no reportaba de
manera transparente las cifras de
muertos por Kobe 19 el gobierno decidió
informar de la situación de la pandemia
en el último mes tras poner fin
abruptamente a su política de cero covid
nuestro análisis muestra que desde el
ocho de diciembre de 2022 hasta el 12 de
enero de 2023 se produjeron un total de
59,938 muertes relacionadas con el Coby
19 en instituciones médicas de todo el
país entre ellas 5.503 muertes se
debieron a insuficiencia respiratoria
causada por la infección de Kobe 19 y
54,435 muertes resultaron de las
enfermedades subyacentes combinadas con
Kobe 19
Esta es la primera vez que china muestra
una cifras tan altas durante la pandemia
hasta el momento Beijing solo reportaba
poco más de 5000 fallecimientos desde el
inicio de la crisis sanitaria una de las
cifras más bajas del mundo a pesar de
contar con la mayor del planeta con más
de 1400 millones de habitantes las
fuertes protestas suscitadas por esta
política obligaron al gobierno de
levantar las restricciones y ahora el
gobierno asegura que el pico de
contagios ha pasado y la tendencia es a
la baja pero expertos subrayan que no se
tienen en cuenta las posibles
consecuencias del año nuevo lunar chino
que se celebra el 22 de enero y que
implica la migración de seres humanos
más grande del mundo el gobierno chino
se está preparando para esta migración
masiva de seres humanos para evitar lo
que yo llamo un cóctel explosivo de
covid 19 que si logran superar ese mes
ese esa última semana del mes de enero
van a poder superar En mi opinión lo que
de verdad representa el posible pico del
virus en la República popular china
contradiciendo los argumentos oficiales
el viernes el ex jefe de epidemiólogos
del centro de control de enfermedades
chino afirmaba que el pico de contagio
se mantendrá durante febrero y marzo